versuche an gesunden embryos livestream
aus dem all und neues von der
kernforschungsanlage wendelstein 7-x das
sind drei der fünf themen jetzt bei den
klicks um top 5 - wasserstoff plasma ein
gigantischer erfolg anfang dezember 2015
berichteten wir schon einmal von der
kernforschungsanlage in greifswald schon
da verzeichnete die kern
forschungsanlage wendelstein 7-x einen
meilenstein der energieforschung die
forscher des max-planck-instituts für
plasmaphysik kurze pp haben in der
vakuumkammer zehn milligramm helium für
rund eine zehntelsekunde auf eine
temperatur von rund eine million grad
celsius gebracht da doch ist ein extrem
heißes und nicht das helium plassmann
stammten mit diesem plasma könnte man in
zukunft auf der erde eine kleine
künstliche sonne erstellen bei diesen
hohen temperaturen kommt es nämlich zu
einer kernfusion zwei atomkerne
verschmelzen hier zu einem kern auf der
sonne da draußen passiert dass die ganze
zeit bei 15 grad celsius und dabei wird
sehr sehr viel energie freigesetzt im
gegensatz zur sonne konnten die forscher
im dezember 2015 ein helium plasma
erzeugen um tatsächlich eine künstliche
sonne betreiben zu können braucht man
wasserstoff plasma dass es uns menschen
gelingt ein wasserstoff plasma zu
erzeugen schienen vor fast zwei monaten
noch in weiter ferne zu sein
den experten des max planck instituts
für plasmaforschung ist es aber mal
wieder gelungen einen großen fortschritt
zu verzeichnen innerhalb einer halben
stunde nach versuch start gelang es
wasserstoff plasma zu erzeugen was aber
hat das jetzt zu bedeuten
sie tat die grundstoffe für die fusion
deuterium und lithium aus dem im
kraftwerk tritium hergestellt wird sind
fast unerschöpflicher menge überall auf
der welt vorhanden
ein gramm brennstoff könnte so viel
energie freisetzen wie elf tonnen kohle
so die experten des ep übrigens die
wendelstein 7-x anlage wurde im jahr
1990 geplant und jetzt 26 jahre später
also uhr 26 jahre später gelingt mit
dieser anlage ein meilenstein
sondersgleichen die erzeugung eines
wasserstoff placements
europäisches daten relais systeme im all
daten auf knopfdruck wenn man von
satellitenbildern spricht dann denken
viele dass diese jederzeit per
knopfdruck abrufbar sind und einfach an
die erde geschickt werden
das ist allerdings nicht so wirklich so
dass daten signal auf der erde ankommen
das dauert sehr sehr lange dauer sogar
oft stunden benötigt man zum beispiel
bei einer naturkatastrophe daten dauert
das eben ein bisschen zu lang
die europäische weltraumorganisation
kurz esa und das unternehmen airbus
haben sich diesem problem ist aber
gestellt
gemeinsam arbeiten sie am so genannten e
wäre es dem europäischen daten relais
system mit hilfe der kommunikations
satelliten eutelsat 9b wollen sie ein
netzwerk aufbauen das innerhalb von 15
minuten erreichbar ist und das zu können
muss aber eben eine relaisstation des
typs e d rsa und eben ein
eutelsat 9b satellit ins all
transportiert werden ähnlich wie der
start der ariane 5 und dem wir letzte
woche berichteten konnte auch der staat
und transport der beiden bauteile ohne
komplikationen durchgeführt werden in
einer höhe von 36.000 kilometern kreisen
diese jetzt und verrichten ihre arbeit
die idee rsa relaisstation fängt mit
hilfe einer laser technologie
informationen anderer satelliten ein und
schickt sie über den heute sagt man
satelliten zur erbe die kosten für das
europäische daten release system
belaufen sich übrigens auf rund 500
millionen euro das klingt vielleicht
viel aber die investition könnte sehr
nützlich sein zum beispiel bei einem
erdbeben wie letztes jahr nepal könnten
mit dem neuen netzwerk dann schon
innerhalb einer viertelstunde
satellitenbilder zur unterstützung der
einsatzkräfte benutzt werden
bleiben wir direkt im all es gab nämlich
kürzlich ein livestream aus dem all
für schüler und lehrer der britische
astronom pete beantwortete einer schule
in liverpool alle möglichen fragen
direkt von der international space
station iss
neben den fragen zeigt er auch noch
einige dinge die man so nur in der
schwerelosigkeit erleben kann
was das genau war das seht ihr jetzt in
einem kleinen ausschnitt des livestreams
den link zur ganzen aufzeichnung findet
ihr in der video beschreibung versuche
mit gesunden embryos die britische band
embryology authority kurz besuchen an
gesunden menschlichen embryos forscher
des francis crick instituts wollen die
gene von menschlichen embryos mit hilfe
des chris brown ein verfahren
selektieren bzw manipulieren im
speziellen geht es um die gene die nach
der befruchtung zu vorschein kommen
im zuge der experimente sollen diese
gene verändert beziehungsweise
teilstücke der gene entfernt werden
die wissenschaftler wollen so eine
methode finden mit der sich die
unfruchtbarkeit therapieren lässt in der
vergangenheit wurden schon einmal
experimente mit nicht lebensfähigen
embryos genehmigt aber bei den versuchen
des francis crick instituts handelt es
sich um lebensfähige das heißt die
forscher experimentieren mit potenziell
lebensfähigen menschen die embryos sind
übrigens sozusagen restbestände einer
künstlichen befruchtung bei einer
solchen befruchtung werden nämlich nicht
alle im beruf eingesetzt ist auch im
logisch die erlaubnis der age erreicht
allerdings noch nicht aus um die
forschung zu beginnen auch wenn die
embryos restbestände sind und nach der
versuchsreihe zerstört und nicht in eine
gebärfähige gebärmutter eingesetzt
werden sollen stellt sich die kritikern
die frage nach der ethik bei diesen
versuchen neben der behörde muss
deswegen auch die ethikkommission ihre
erlaubnis erteilen ob sie das tut oder
nicht dazu gibt es noch kein statement
die forscher müssen sich also noch etwas
gedulden
social media konsum zerstört deinen
schlafrhythmus wer zuviel auf social
media plattform unterwegs ist der könnte
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit eine
belastende schlafstörung entwicklung
betrachtet man das ergebnis einer neu
veröffentlichten vergleichsstudie der
universität pittsburgh kommen die
forscher zu diesem ergebnis die
wissenschaftler der universität führten
im rahmen ihrer studie einer umfrage mit
über 1700 amerikanern durch die
befragten man alle zwischen 19 und 32
jahre alt sie beantworten fragen zu
ihrem social media konsum und ihren
schlafrhythmus im fokus standen vor
allem die social media plattformen
facebook youtube twitter google plus
instagram snapshot rettet tumblr
interest wein und linkedin
ergebnis fast ein drittel der probanden
und probanden leiden an akuten
schlafstörungen im zeitraum von sieben
tagen nutzen die meisten über eine
stunde eine oder mehrere der plattform
mehr so viel zeit mit social media
plattform verbrachte der hätte auch
häufig mit einer schlafstörung zu
kämpfen
so berichteten die forscher in ihrer
studie warum das ergebnis der studie so
deutlich war können die experten noch
nicht sagen
in weiterführenden untersuchungen wollen
sie jetzt herausfinden was genau im
zusammenhang mit social media plattform
die schlafhygiene kaputt macht sind es
die damit verbundenen emotionen oder
liegt es an den reizen die
beispielsweise von bildschirmen
aktiviert werden wie geht es euch damit
habt ihr selbst schon mal an euch
festgestellt dass sich an euren
schlafgewohnheiten irgendetwas geändert
hat und wenn ja warum noch eine frage an
euch bei der ich wirklich gespannt bin
was ihr dazu sagt was haltet ihr von
versuchen mit den lebensfähigen embryos
lasst eure meinung in den kommentaren
da vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren kostet ja nix und schaut euch
das letzte video an da gab es nämlich
ein gewinnspiel und das gewinnspiel
läuft noch also vor ein link zu dem
video findet ihr auch in der video
beschreibung und bis dahin wünsche ich
euch noch ein schönes rest wochenende
und einen guten start in die woche
bis dann